for me it's it's very interesting how we
as people don't even take a step back to
think on
why we do that even like slack is not
forcing us to go in
but what happens is the notification
sound or the color
red makes your brain react before
yourself in a way
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on my
20 milliliters show how are you good how
are you
fantastic it's so great to have you here
some technical issues to start but
that's part of the
of the virtual lifestyle that we have
unfortunately we can't be in the studio
doing this face to face
we'll settle for this emna a we have so
much to talk about from your startup
family
and all the way to digital well-being
let's start off easy and and then
accelerate as we go along
who are you amna gariani all right wow
that's a long question so i'm the ceo
and co-founder of the
vmp is a unified workspace for
developers our goal is to help them
focus better stay in flow remove
distractions uh so we give them a
centralized workspace for all
for their non-coding apps and we give
them a smart feed of their conversations
on top
um are you uh are you saying referring
to the fact that there are tr
there are distractions when we are
online yes
so the problem is today all of us even
beyond developers when we open our
laptop our cortisol level is high by
default our
stress is high our focus is down just
because we have so many tabs open so
many apps and
we get in traffic yeah we get
interrupted every 11 minutes on average
and takes about over 20 minutes to focus
again so when you think about it like
you know
we're all the time in non-focused mode
and we end up staying late and
we're working over the weekend and
burning out and we we don't
second to stop and think pretty much so
that's uh
that's why pretty much so is this is
this new so is this something
if i look at the workforce you know 50
years ago people are working
everywhere is this a new problem that we
have
absolutely actually it's funny you say
that because i always talk about the
evolution of communication
so 20 years ago 50 years a bit too far
we didn't have a
computers like we did today at least we
didn't use them uh
we didn't have computers like we did
today so uh 20 years ago however
communication used to happen via
on two main channels uh of course that
had a lot of issues like scattered
information silo effects and
in the past few years we've seen an
explosion of collaboration apps and work
apps and
now there's literally an app for
everything and there is no streamlined
process
so we are here not to streamline the
process between all these apps and help
people better
leverage and optimize their time in the
hope to help them get to their work life
balance
so yeah but what does that even mean so
how do you go and help
people avoid distractions optimize their
time be more productive in the moment
very good question so for us what we do
in veeamly so it's a desktop app so you
have access to all your different apps
and on top you have your smart feed but
we have a mode where you can go from
sync to async
so when you are in async mode you have
no interruptions you still have your
smart inbox being filled up with all
your conversations and then we have a
soft alert system
to help users understand that they need
to look at something but if they're in
flow it's not going to interrupt them
and then what we do is we bring them
awareness on how they're using their
time and we give them insights to help
them really
educate themselves better so with vmi
they get at least an hour back a day
wow so you know i think that's just
fascinating because as i'm reflecting
now on my experience
i'm a software engineer at hippo
insurance and i love i love the
experience and one of the interesting
things is that i've noticed that
now that everybody's remote and there's
no casual meetings i can't stand up and
go meet somebody in the office
my slack message is that i'm getting i
almost feel the responsibility of
answering them as if somebody came up to
my desk and spoke to me
and that that that is a that is
distracting because as i'm
coding or doing something else i feel
compelled to in real time answer
everybody
it's not like an email where i feel okay
it's fine if i take two three hours
because i don't check my email every
five seconds right
so what is i love what you're saying
because for me it's
it's very interesting how we as people
don't even take a step back to think on
why we do that even like slack is not
forcing us to go in
but what happens is the notification
sound or the color
red makes your brain react before
yourself in a way
so that creates this fake sense of
urgency
and this also formal effect right the
fear of missing out so
before you knowing it's one of your
colleagues sharing a puppy
picture and it's not system everything
is fine you're already distracted you're
already looking at it you're already
interacting with it
beyond that you also have your comments
on your jira tickets and your comments
on your pull request and every single
thing like
comes and it's a notification or it's an
interruption
and today there is no way to prioritize
to know what to focus on or not
and it's very detrimental to your focus
to your flow
and it's stress that we don't even feel
for me i will say this like
there's two types of stress right then
i'm not
scientific or doctor i'm like there's a
stress that you feel and there's a
stress that you don't feel that's living
everywhere in your body in your in your
lower back and your wrists everywhere
and you don't realize it's happening
and all these small things contribute to
it sure
but we're not um accounting for them
that's why we talk about my
productivity in that sense so yeah so
what is the actual solution it's a dash
of application that i come in and i
and i go into this new world this async
world where now
a lot of my messages becoming soft
notifications and smart alerts systems
tell me a little bit more about the
experience that i'll have using using
that
absolutely as a developer you open
veeamly you have access to your slack to
your jira your github like we're not
like anytime you need to do actual work
and those you'll access them from there
but on top we have a one single pane of
glass where
it's prioritized for you but what needs
your action and what is your attention
so immediately you know uh how to
prioritize your time on what to address
first so
everything else that's not priority
right now we'll put it in another tab
and you can go look at it later
also the way we prioritize is based on
the user preferences so
as they start they decide what goes into
their feed we're not here to do that
but also we have obviously some um
algorithms to help prioritize it are
some of their logical some of their
smart based on behavior and semantics
um and so that's the first level and
then on top of that they have unified
search where they can search for any
information really easily
and uh as i mentioned they have like
this mode sync versus async
and when they are in async mode then we
have a soft alert system that doesn't
interrupt them if they're in flow but if
they're not then
it will let them know there is more
stuff to look at the thing is in
an interruption or a distraction is not
a bad thing that is actually proven it
was great for creativity
but it's an unplanned distraction or
interruption is that's the one that's
bad for you
so for us we help you plan your
distractions in a way
and prioritize your time while
streamlining all your communications
so give me a little bit of the context
and a little bit of statistics because
i'm sure that that's something that
you've been
mixing around and so how many ever so
how many
notifications does the average developer
get let's say a day
or how many times how much time does it
waste you mentioned something earlier
very good so people get developers get
at least 100 messages a day across their
different apps so this is
a combination of slack messages yeah
and that's and and it's 100 is a very
small number by the way it goes by very
fast so
it's 100 messages between their slack
messages between their comments on jira
tickets between their comments on their
pull requests
jira or whatever other app obviously
they're using uh but they're ticketing
apps so
between those they spend on average two
minutes on each so
that's a total of three hours or 20
minutes a day
and then a couple hour meeting right
especially in a remote world that's five
hours and 20 minutes
so theoretically in an eight-hour day
that gives them an hour and 40 minutes
of true focus
time which of course does not happen
unfortunately the developer
uh community has always been guilty of
not being great at their work-life
balance
so they tend to burn up really quickly
they don't take days off they don't
like they do they don't put themselves
at the forefront
at the same time every app out there
that's about developers
it's all about code it's all about
products it's not about them as people
so and for us we're like we come from
that background we build products we've
seen it
and we want to care about them as people
because as they are more balanced
everybody everything else will go even
better more productive better for the
company better for everybody
so and that's what you believe how did
you
get started with this whole this whole
idea
um so before this i used to run a
company doing cpo as a service so chief
product officer as a service
so i'd act like an interim cpo to
non-tech founders and i bring my team of
designers and engineers and then we
build the product and take it to market
depending on the needs of the
company and that's kind of where it hits
me how the
work is broken and um so yeah
based on my background i have a large
background in process optimization
and communication and ops in general so
for me
uh it was a it was a no-brainer to go
after this and before that i
i i did help launch over 40 startups as
a director at the founder institute
wow so i've seen the problem elsewhere
as well
and that's what got me to like kind of
my path was that way like i helped other
companies then i want to start
my own company but i wanted to figure
out what they saw for the world
and that's kind of how i got there so
yeah right
digital well-being it goes side by side
with productivity in the sense that
you're trying to understand how people
engage with their digital environments
not necessarily to optimize their work a
productivity right or output but to also
maximize their their well-being and
talk to me a little bit about that i
don't think i know nearly enough and i'm
just starting out in my own career so
this is definitely something that i want
to take with me
as i continue my journey as an engineer
but also as an entrepreneur and
hopefully leader
great uh so digital well-being is
definitely a combination of different
things
the problem is that when we try to throw
software it's a problem
i mean that was a weird sentence but you
get my point like throwing software as a
solution at the problem like this
is gonna solve it i will say this like
beamly as a software itself is a
band-aid
the true solution is going to be what
comes with it which is
what we help people achieve it's like
when you buy a pack of cigarettes and
says smoking kills
that's kind of the goal to do for to to
educate people
on really how distractions and
notifications are really um
killing their day and their life and
their well-being like for example
i have been notification free for almost
two years now
and it's everybody's shocked i'm scared
you're shocked exactly right you're
scared you're shocked and people are
like
how do you do that right like how like
you're a ceo you're running a company
you're doing all these things
and i always challenge people to try it
for three days
the first time you feel true withdrawal
like for me the first time
especially the first three days like
when i started i felt like something is
missing literally it was like almost
like a drug
that's how i realized how bad it is even
more right so
like uh for us definitely that's at the
core of what we're doing in terms of
helping people think differently
about those but beyond that it's the
small things that you implement in your
day-to-day
that help you do better so even being
conscious about the problem
disconnecting from screens
like you know for me you'll never find
my phone next to me and if you find it
next to me
it's all screened down right so it's
like getting in the habit of
reducing distractions so a lot of things
enter
in making us more productive and more
balanced and that's your sleep quality
your water intake
even the weight but before we before we
continue there i have to go back a
little bit because i have to ask
this idea of no notifications as a ceo
you know
at the end throughout this show and
filming over 200 episodes one of the
one of the really interesting things
that have been coming up is this idea of
being
connected and being responsive a lot of
people are really
taking responsiveness seriously and and
it always amazes me how very very busy
people
respond very very quickly to my emails
or my messages
how do you be how do you portray
yourself as a responsive person
and not miss opportunities or allowing
people to count on you
in a world where you're not even aware
necessarily that they're messaging you
so first i love this question because
earlier in my career and not that long
ago really like i obsessed over
responsiveness especially you know when
it's like somebody you qualify as
important whoever that is right
in your world that could be your boss or
whoever it is so it's like you're always
scared
what if i don't answer they think i'm
careless or not i like care pretty much
we're all it's off here right
it all comes from fear at the end of the
day if you're missing out
if you're being perceived wrong and the
thing is i always say this even to my
team it's all about intent
that's number one so i think we put the
wrong
weight on responsiveness because we're
not robots
like you know if i'm not responding to
you it means i'm probably doing
something else i'm responsible
right so if i'm working on a
presentation or working on a product
thing
i don't need to be responding to you
unless it's something super urgent and
then you just call me
right and interrupt me and so the thing
is
is you realize that most people don't
care if you
reply to something within 24 hours
that's when it comes to email right
when it comes to instant messaging like
slack and other things
like it's a matter of an hour or two
which nobody dies unless you're in a
collaboration
mode and your collaboration will need to
schedule that like i talk about
structured synchronous
communication right like there's a whole
debate about i think versus sync i'm
like sync can be
structured right that can be in sync
mode that's how we have this
feature and if i'm in sync mode all
modifications are coming in but it's
fine
because i'm a collaboration mode so i i
never had any issues with responsiveness
since i've been notification free
because i still check
my different apps on a regular basis
right if i'm not doing if i'm done with
the task at hand then i'm gonna go check
my main channels of communication right
so which is i used mainly trello jira
slack
and uh ina these are the four main ones
for me so
yeah and so when you're running your
company now and do all your engineers
have to use
wembley to become to be productive i
hope that for them they're building it
so if they don't believe in it
we'll have a problem right so it's uh
it's not even like for us even the whole
approach
whether it's our engineers or other
engineers out there the whole point is
we're not forcing something on you we're
bringing awareness for you it's kind of
what you said about yourself right right
now
it's like i'm an engineer i see this is
like yeah i want you to realize that for
yourself
and hopefully we help you be more
balanced be more focused
um and do better really so
a hundred percent so back to this back
digital well-being
go back to a little bit to the the scope
of what's happening today and
and a little bit of where we can expect
to be headed especially in covet 19
times when things are a little bit you
know a little bit
tricky we're not really sure of what's
happening and we're not really sure of
our interaction with the virtual
environment for years to come
so this is actually kovit made this
problem even more prominent
and bigger because now we don't have a
separation between our personal life and
our work
uh even though even like for me i've
been running remote for
years right like before this i helped
launch companies remotely in different
countries so
but that always made it a point to
separate my work environment from my
personal
home because it's very hard right that's
why like one of the advice you get
is like in order to be balanced try to
have like your own space try to make it
create some sort of routine et cetera
so back to the digital being aspect of
it in this environment we are in
more than ever we need a sense of
stopping
creating a separation between our
personal life or not for me i talk about
the sense of accomplishment i say with
veenly the whole point is to get you to
that sense of accomplishment
and remove fomo you know things are
there for you so you can see
data about how you're using your time
you know what you have accomplished
today
you know what you need to be doing
tomorrow everything is there for you
it's not going to go anywhere so when
you disconnect you don't have that
stress of like did i miss something
right so beyond that is bringing the
other external factors
more than ever taking care of our health
and our sleep and all these different
things that impact our productivity
are important so for us
when we talk about that and achieving
digital well-being is by bringing those
within being
pretty much like how can we give you
ergonomic nudges how can we give you
like
not just towards how you can improve all
these different things
about your day organizing your day like
a pro pretty much
in order to um get to that balance
and so like i mentioned it goes from
like for me my challenge two years goes
notification free this year my challenge
is a tap free so at the end of every day
to close out all taps
and that's harder because sometimes you
go into a meeting and you forget to go
back to do that so i'm still not perfect
at it
but it's so nice because it forces me to
take just five minutes at the end of
every day
and make sure like you know i place the
different tabs wherever i need to
because
ninety percent of the time you never go
back to all these open tabs
but it's just bad habits so it's like it
takes time so that's why it has to be
incremental we have to be kind to
ourselves
and to achieve true digital well-being
you need to become aware
of how you're spending your time so
awareness it sounds like the number one
key
because for every person the
implementation will likely be a little
bit different
fitting to their own personal needs but
give me some more helpful ideas of what
i can be doing in my daily life to
have better digital well-being and right
now i have to say it's tough because
i'm in front of the screen sometimes 16
17 hours a day
you know both as an engineer but also
running this podcast and
and it's a lot of screen time and i want
to make sure that i'm approaching this
in the healthiest way
so very good question so there are a few
things you can start implementing from
tomorrow first calendar blocking sounds
like trivial but it's a very good tool
because calendar blocking it will help
you be more intentional
about your time because awareness is key
but intent is key too we have
we are opted in by default in our daily
lives today when you subscribe to a
product you're up to them by default
in your workout to them by default you
don't take a second to think about how
you're organizing all this
so if you 10 minutes every night before
the next day or like once a week to
block your whole week
and to make sure to plug your breaks
like being in front of computer for 17
hours
like now what you're very young right
earlier career
what's gonna happen 20 years from now
when you're gonna start having back
pains and
carpal tunnel and all these bad things
like your eyes are gonna go to hell so
all these things were not intentional
about them so
counter blocking amazing tool to help
you schedule your breaks
and realize also be even more focused
because once you have that then you have
that rewarding aspect that's how our
brain works
you have a trigger and then you have a
reward so you know it's like oh if i'm
gonna do this for two hours
i'm gonna take a 30-minute break and
then i'm gonna you know
do something something else on that
break work out or
go for a walk or watch something
whatever it is that you like doing so
that's the number one two sleep sleep
sleep
that's super important we don't give
enough um
weight to the importance of having a
good night's sleep it's
it's important for everything for our
focus but even like for
our bodies our health like even our
workout routine
diet everything so um that's a quote
easy one to also schedule part of
calendar blocking to be like at this
time and
it helps to use technology right like
for me i'm like technology is not bad
it's about how you can leverage
technology to get to your traditional
well-being so
technology is not bad but it can be
misused and then people can
write so if you have an alexa or a
google home or something for a reminder
put a reminder to go to sleep it sounds
trivial but put that create a sleep
routine
like that's the time you okay before
sleeping i want to drink water i want to
read 10 pages of a book and do this
thing
what like create that routine and then
little by little get back to it
the problem is we're lost you know and
we don't know where to get started
that's where it gets really really hard
yep
so these are some of the few things you
can start with they want
i strongly recommend to organize your
phone
i know this is like the phones are our
biggest stressors today
notifications also like when you have
you know five pages of 90 different apps
that you don't use anyway
so if you take five seconds like if you
see my phone screen i have maybe ten
folders like you know one that says work
tools one that says social one
finance and so and all these little
things that are not too hard to
implement they accumulate the
accumulation
and it will create that that incremental
change will adapt to be something really
impactful on you i'm not this is a
wonderful
thank you for being so generous with
your time before we leave i have to ask
you for three words that you would use
to describe yourself
communication process and data all
around people i don't know
so i'll say that's my holy trifecta so
it's like communication process data in
the middle
people at the center so people at the
center i like that amna thank you very
very much
best of luck with family stay safe and
stay healthy and and i love the mission
thank you very much thank you
foreign